started off the Morning by making my
wife's favorite breakfast a chocolate
smoothie with plenty of spinach and a
bagel with butter and honey after
breakfast I took out the trash changed
our flights for Christmas and headed to
the grocery store I got plenty of
groceries for the week and our grand
total from TJ's was
143.19 after putting the food away and
getting some work done on my computer I
headed to the gym after the gym I
grabbed some coffee with a friend and
wow where has the day gone because the
sun's already going down once I got home
I meal prepped for Lucy's lunches for
the next couple of days I made salmon
bowls with rice broccoli and Sriracha
mayo after meal prepping I cleaned our
whole apartment scrubbing our bathroom
vacuuming the floors and mopping as well
once Lucy got home I had a little
surprise for her fresh flowers her
favorite sweet treat and a little
handwritten note too I'm so proud of
this girl in all that she's
accomplishing right now so anything I
can do to support her living her dreams
makes me so happy
she is so not into the sky at all you
could tell